la journée des bleus yann lavoix vous le
disais tout à l'heure est loin d'être
terminée elle avait commencé ce matin
dès la sortie du centre mitic de
clairefontaine la retraite des bleus
là où se sont succédé les entraînements
et les périodes de repos christelle
bertrand et laurent hamida ont suivi
l'équipe de france toute cette journée
si vous voulez savoir où se trouve
l'équipe de france
vous n'avez qu'à suivre les banderoles
ce matin elle a commencé par la
fédération française de football
les traits sont un peu tirés le sommeil
ils y penseront plus tard c'est à dire
j'ai fait j'ai fait la fête avec mes
amis à l'hôtel la folie était à
clairefontaine fiers comme des champions
du monde ils chérissent leur couper la
partage avec le public
la fête a commencé dans le car 70
kilomètres d'échauffement avant le
bouquet final
zidane est passé de meneur de jeu à
meneur de revue
sur le chemin même les feux rouge vire
au bleu
les supporters veulent montrer leur
amour les joueurs leur ont donné tant de
bonheur des milliers de personnes
ouvrent la route aux champions du monde
on se croirait sur une étape du tour de
france acclamé les joueurs font un
dernier petit coucou avant d'aller
dormir un peu certains n'ont pas dormi
du tout sous la pluie ils ont attendu 10
heures ce matin pour voir passer
l'équipe dans l'autre sens une dernière
fois
mais la fête n'est pas finie on est
serrés l'apprécier du mieux possible ce
que hier soir on s'en est pas trop rendu
compte belge en a fêté ses un trait
prépare maintenant on va on se retrouve
encore entre nous et partager une
victoire ça se fait forcément sur les
champs elysées les joueurs se sont
installés sur un bus à impériale
tout le monde se tient au courant de la
suite des événements avant de remonter
la plus belle avenue du monde
ils l'ont bien mérité